[Music]
welcome back
so i'm really excited today to tell you
about gauss's divergence theorem this is
one of the most important results in all
of vector calculus
and it is probably the primary building
block of how we derive conservation laws
from from physics from from science
conservation of mass momentum and energy
and translate those into partial
differential equations
so
i'm going to walk you through this
theorem kind of with pictures with words
with math
so the idea is that we have some
some volume
v
and we're going to say that this has a
surface s
and that there is some normal vector
kind of at every point
on the surface of this volume
and so what gauss's theorem does is it
essentially tells us if we have some
fluid flow some vector field uh i'm just
going to draw some some vector field
kind of going throughout all of space
like this and my vector field i'm going
to call
f arrow
so if i have that vector field and it's
carrying you know mass or momentum or
energy
through this volume
gauss's divergence theorem is going to
allow me to compute how much of that
material is kind of fluxing through the
surface
of this this closed surface or what is
the rate of change of that material in
this volume
so it's a really
useful way of doing essentially a
counting
of physical quantities that we know are
conserved like mass momentum and energy
and using those to get quantitative
expressions
now
one of the things that uh
i i think is really important is
intuitively motivating why we want
gauss's theorem so when i learned about
this it was essentially just written
down as a mathematical fact
uh and it was proven
and i i think that's almost a crime not
to tell you all of the cool physical
applications of gauss's divergence
theorem so i'm going to uh write it out
in words
give you the mathematical expression and
then show you uh how we actually use
this to compute partial differential
equations so this is one of the lectures
i'm most excited
for
because i think this is going to be a
tool set or or a tool in your arsenal
that you're going to use for the rest of
your career this is a really powerful
way of thinking about the world
i mean it has gauss's name in it if it's
gauss's divergence theorem it's probably
the best divergence theorem
okay so let's get started um so i'm
going to start in words so kind of words
and i'm going to write this out somewhat
slowly and then we're going to write out
the math expression so in words what
we're saying is that the flux of a
vector field
the flux of a vector field
uh and our vector field uh is f right um
the flux of vector field f
out of a closed surface so uh through or
out let's say through
a closed surface
uh and this closed surface is
uh s
okay this uh the perimeter of this
volume s
so the flux of a vector field through
this closed surface
is equal to the integral of the
divergence of that vector field
throughout the entire volume so i'm
going to say this again and write it
the flux of our vector field through the
surface
is equal
to
the integral
the integral
of the divergence of our vector field
the divergence
div
f
over the entire volume
and i'll just write it here over
the
entire
enclosed
volume v
okay so this is a bit of a mouthful and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
walk you through what this statement
means why it's important and we're going
to translate it into a mathematical
expression
so maybe i will um
kind of uh almost start with the
mathematical expression and then we'll
go back to what these words mean
so okay the flux of a vector field f
through a surface
and i'm going to write this out in math
um maybe i will write it in blue
so the flux of our vector field through
this surface is going to be a surface
integral so i'm going to
integrate
over my surface s
and the flux is essentially how much of
f is pointing in the normal direction
added up over every little surface
element
so if i want to compute at every point
how much of f is
is being kind of carried out of this
volume
what i do
is i take my my f vector
and i take my normal vector
n
and i dot them together and that tells
me how much of my f component is in a
direction that will actually take me out
of this volume
so let's think for a minute if my f
vector field was just swirling around in
this volume kind of going around in
circles and it had no component that was
perpendicular to the volume then nothing
would be carried out
of this volume through that vector field
it would just be kind of recirculating
but nothing would be leaving and that
dot product of f if it was
tangent to the normal
would be zero dot product with n
and so the way we say this is the
surface integral
of our vector field f
dotted with the normal
integrated over over that volume over
every little area element on the
perimeter of this
so this is the flux of the vector field
f this is literally the definition of
what i mean by the flux this is how much
stuff is being carried out of the volume
it's this we compute how
much of f is pointing in the normal
direction using the dot product and we
integrate that up over the entire
surface and that's how much stuff is
leaving the volume this is basic
accounting this is the only way stuff
can leave the volume okay unless unless
we believe that stuff can be created or
destroyed inside the volume okay so if
if
if our quantity like mass momentum or
energy can't be created or destroyed
and it's conserved then this is a basic
accounting of how much stuff leaves
through that surface s
and so we call this the flux
through s the flux
through
s and this is like a definition of the
flux
and what gauss's divergence theorem says
is that this flux this might actually be
kind of a pain to compute maybe i don't
want to do the surface integral
what this is equal to
is a volume integral so we'll do a
triple volume integral over the entire
volume
of the divergence of f
of um
div dot
f
dv
and this is extremely useful so what
this says is that these two quantities
are completely equivalent ways of
computing the flux through uh some
volume and this is for an arbitrary
volume it doesn't matter what size v is
it could be a skinny little rod it could
be
a sphere
it could be you know a little hockey
puck shaped thing it doesn't matter what
this volume is this is always true as
long as f is a continuous vector field
if it doesn't have like sharp abrupt
changes or shock waves then this is
going to be true this is gauss's
divergence theorem
and this is really important so i'm
actually going to box this off this is
super important this is um gauss's
divergence theorem we'll put some stars
next to it just so that we remember that
this is you know really really important
results
okay so i'm going to restate why this is
true
i'm going to show you some intuition of
why this expression should equal this
expression
and then we're going to use this to
actually compute
some real conservation laws and
translate those into partial
differential equations okay things like
the mass continuity equation or the navy
or stokes equation
good
um okay so why do we think that this
volume integral of the divergence of f
should equal the amount of stuff being
carried out of f
so i'm going to draw another little
picture here kind of i'm going to try my
best to to duplicate this so that we can
play around
okay so that's roughly my
volume and what we're going to do is
we're going to chop this up into a
number of little
little boxes so i'm going to chop this
up into some boxes
and i'm not you know a fantastic artist
so we're just going to use a few boxes
here
and what we're going to do is look at
the divergence in each of these boxes so
in your imagination imagine that this is
a really fine graph paper with you know
millions or trillions of boxes
and you could take the limit as all of
those boxes become infinitesimally small
that's what we're going to do
and we're going to look at the
divergence
at every little uh
grid box in this this graph paper
representation so at every little point
here what i'm going to do is i'm going
to draw a representation of
of the divergence
and what we're going to have
is that maybe i have you know some
positive divergence here and some
positive divergence here let's say my
flow is kind of you know expanding
and some positive divergence okay i'm
just going to draw this i'm not going to
draw any of these negative because it's
a little harder to visualize
and i've got this guy here
now the idea
is and this is again this is requiring
that my vector field f is continuous
to do the the divergence theorem to kind
of take this limit as all of these grid
cells become infinitesimally small
and the argument i'm about to to give
you
is the following okay and i really like
this picture it just looks super cool
so
these pink uh sources the way i'm
drawing them here these are the
divergence fields locally that are
induced by this this flow f so this f
might be doing something complicated
um you know there's some complicated
physics navier stokes fluid flow
whatever and this is the local
divergence at every little point
now what we observe
is that
if i really do assume that this this
vector field is continuous and i make
this grid infinitesimally fine
then these neighboring boxes kind of the
positive upward component of this flux
and the negative downward component of
this flux should cancel each other out
because if i make my boxes small enough
the the flow is basically identical in
neighboring boxes and so the upward
component of this pushing on the
downward component of this cancel out
and so you actually get this kind of
cancellation of all of the inner boxes
every box that shares a wall
those two neighboring forces are going
to kind of cancel each other out
and the only thing that you're going to
be left with
is this kind of thin perimeter
of all of the divergences
that don't have
a neighboring grid cell so kind of all
of these these little boxes that are
pointing out
this is the only thing that's left when
i integrate over this volume
okay so i'm going to say this again
when i integrate all of my divergences
over this volume when i integrate all of
my divergence on this volume all of the
inner grid cells kind of cancel each
other out because of the continuity of f
because f is a continuous vector field
and i'm making these these boxes
infinitesimally small
the
you know the right vector and the left
vector on neighboring grid cells cancel
each other out and the up vector and the
down vector on neighboring grid cells
cancel each other out and so we only
have this thin perimeter right on the
surface
of our volume
that don't have uh divergence vectors
that are being cancelled out
and you'll notice that if i integrate
these along that looks a heck of a lot
like my flux
through through the volume
so this is a very cartoony sketch of why
gauss's divergence theorem is true
it's because i can take
i can integrate this flow kind of dotted
with the normal along the surface
or i can compute its divergence
everywhere throughout the volume and
just add up all of those divergences
the ones in the middle will cancel each
other out and it will leave kind of
something that's equivalent to this
integral on the perimeter
so that's a really useful in my mind
kind of cartoon of why this is
why this is true okay so let's uh
the way i talk about this uh when i'm
teaching this in class
this is essentially just accounting this
is uh you know being counting of some
quantity being flown through a vector
field
and so as long as you can count things
you know this these arguments have to be
true the stuff coming into a volume has
to equal the stuff coming out of a
volume unless you have sources you know
that are kind of creating things or
destroying things inside the volume
okay good
and there's a lot of ways you can
compute with this so
for example if i want to compute the
volume of an irregular shape
i can create a vector field that has
divergence
divergence 1
and i can integrate that vector field
all along the perimeter of my volume
i'm going to say that again
if i want to compute the volume of an
irregular object
all i have to do is create a vector
field that has divergence one
and then i integrate that vector field
along the perimeter or along the surface
of my volume dotted in the normal
direction that will equal the volume
of that object so that's kind of a neat
application of gauss's theorem but
that's a little esoteric
what i really really really want to show
you is how we can use this to derive
partial differential equations so let me
just say gauss's divergence theorem
for
pdes for partial differential equations
and this is really exciting okay
so all of our modern physics all of uh
kind of you know the textbook equations
that you're you're used to seeing the
navy or stokes equations you know
maxwell's equations almost all of our
physical laws
boil down to a conservation of some
quantity in some volume using gauss's
theorem to derive a partial differential
equation so it's an extremely extremely
powerful way of mathematically
quantifying uh physics and that's what
i'm going to show you right now
so we're going to look at
gauss's theorem for the conservation of
mass in a volume okay so we're going to
specifically look
at
mass conservation
mass conservation
uh in a volume
and we're basically assuming that we
have some fluid flow
you know uh maybe we're in the gulf of
mexico maybe this is the flow in the
ocean and maybe i have some oil spill at
some point in the in the gulf of mexico
maybe that's what this this uh this
volume is or maybe there's some some
spill here
and we know that that is a conserved
quantity there's not you know more or
less um you know at least in the short
term
as it flows through and so we want to
somehow quantify this conservation
uh of mass in our volume
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to say
that our total mass let me see i want to
write that here so our
total
mass
in the volume
equals
the triple integral
over v
of the density rho
dv okay so i'll just say rho is the
density
so the density of whatever my fluid is
if i integrate that whole
you know that density over the entire
volume i will get the mass
in that volume
and so the rate of change of that mass
and the volume
is equal to how much of that flow that
mass is being fluxed out of that volume
through this surface integral
so that's what i want to write down this
is the the basic conservation i want to
write down so the
so d dt
of this
integral which is
rho
dv integrated over the volume this is
the total this is the rate of change of
mass in my volume so maybe mass is being
carried out of my volume maybe mass is
coming into my volume
and it's happening because this vector
field this fluid flow is either carrying
mass in or carrying mass out
and so this rate of change equals the
only way that that mass can enter or
leave this volume is through it being
carried out through the boundary
by this flow f
so this would equal
minus
the integral through the surface
of my you know my mass that's being
carried out
through the normal direction d s
and i have this minus sign because
essentially if i have a positive flow
carrying mass out of my volume if this f
dot n is a positive thing carrying flow
out then that is a negative rate of
change of mass inside the volume
so the rate of change of mass inside the
volume is equal to minus how much of it
is leaving the volume
and again this is the only way mass can
leave the volume is that if it's carried
out
through this flow kind of normal to uh
to that volume
okay so this is this is the basic setup
this is again just a counting this is
just counting the mass in my volume here
and counting how much mass enters and
leaves my volume here
good
but what we want these are are this is a
triple integral and this is a double
integral and what we want is to somehow
you know write these in the same triple
integral formulation so i want to
convert this into a triple volume
integral and i'm going to use gauss's
divergence theorem to do that so we're
going to turn this into a triple
integral by using gauss's divergence
theorem
and the way we do it
is as follows so we're going to say
this quantity here
is equal
to minus
the triple volume integral
of the divergence of this quantity
right so the the surface integral of
some flux dotted with a normal is equal
to the volume integral of the divergence
of that vector field
so this is divergence of rho
f
dv
and remember rho my density is just a
scalar it's just a number at every point
in space and f is a vector field it's my
flow that's carrying this mass in and
out
so now i have an apples to apples uh
kind of comparison before it was apples
and oranges i had a volume integral and
a flux surface integral now i have a
volume integral for the rate of change
in time of my mass
equal to this kind of spatial divergence
of rho times my vector field f
and so what's really neat about this
is that i can move this over to the left
hand side
and now i can put everything under the
same triple volume integral and i'm
going to move my ddt inside of here okay
and and this is really going to be a
partial of rho
rho is a function uh let me write this
down
so my density uh rho is a function of
space let's say x y
z
but also of time okay this density might
be changing i might have a compressible
fluid you know if i'm flying a jet the
air is compressing and the density is
changing as that wing or the nose or
whatever is hitting the air okay so
sometimes this can change in space and
time it can vary
and so what i'm going to eventually get
when i bring this all under the integral
is that i have a triple
volume integral
of uh partial rho
partial t the partial derivative of rho
with respect to time
now this minus when i bring it over
becomes a plus plus
the divergence of rho
times my fluid velocity field
all of this
dv
equals zero
so this is pretty special okay this uh
equation here essentially
accounts for all of the change of mass
due to uh like the mass changing in time
things fluxing through the surface and
things like that
and when you add that all up it has to
equal zero this is a statement of
conservation of mass
now here is one of my favorite parts of
this whole story of how you use gauss's
divergence theorem to derive partial
differential equations
is that
this is true
this is true
for all volumes
for all volumes
v this is true if i had a big volume v a
stretched out volume v it's also true if
i take my v
and i take the limit as it becomes a
teeny tiny tiny little delta v this is
true at every little patch uh in space
if i shrink my volume down to that
little patch in space this is still true
and the only way that this integral can
equal zero for all volumes
is if the thing inside of it equals zero
everywhere
and so this is how we derive our partial
differential equation this thing inside
has to be equal to zero for this volume
integral to equal zero on all volumes
and so then we finally get partial rho
partial t
plus the divergence of rho
times my vector field f
equals zero
and this is called the mass continuity
equation
mass continuity
continuity equation
and it's one of the fundamental
equations in fluid mechanics this is the
equation that quantifies conservation of
mass in a flowing fluid in the air when
i'm speaking you know air is moving but
it's still the mass is conserved this
room
mass is not being created or destroyed
and so this equation is true everywhere
in in space and in time okay even if i
have a jet moving through even if it's a
compressible fluid flow this is still
true
um
it is only not true
when uh when my
vector field f is sufficiently or my
density rho
is sufficiently non-continuous if it has
a really sharp step change in space or
in time
then this these derivatives don't
actually make sense they would go to
infinity and i can only represent kind
of the integral
effect in a control volume that's large
enough to include that discontinuity
okay
so
what i'm going to do i'm going to take a
step back and summarize and i think in
the next video i'm probably going to dig
a little bit deeper into this mass
conservation equation and show you what
happens for example
if i have an incompressible flow if my
density is a constant then we can get
specific kind of we can derive specific
quantities that have to be true for this
fluid flow f
okay but let's talk about the whole
pipeline here
if i have
physics physics is generally written in
terms of conservation laws we have
conservation of mass conservation of
momentum conservation of energy newton's
second law is essentially a statement of
conservation of mass
uh sorry conservation of momentum okay
you know the rate of change of momentum
is equal to the forces applied to the
system
we can encode those conservation laws
through integral equations like this we
literally count how much stuff we have
in a volume and how much it changes in
time
and we say that the only way that that
can
that the amount of stuff in that volume
can change that mass or momentum or
energy is if it enters or leaves through
the surface of that volume so i have a
volume integral for the rate of change
of stuff equals a surface integral for
how much stuff enters or leaves through
the boundary
and gauss's theorem what gauss's theorem
allows us to do is turn that surface
integral into a volume integral
so now i can kind of use apples to
apples i can i can add up everything
under one common integral and i now have
this partial derivative expression
that has to equal zero everywhere over
all volumes
and again if f and if the quantity i'm
adding up if my mass and my momentum or
my energy and my fluid flow are
continuous
smoothly varying in space and time
then this is true for all volumes and i
can get rid of the volume integral and i
get my partial differential equation
so this is how most
of the pdes that you're used to from
classical physics are derived is by
writing down a conservation law and then
using gauss's theorem to kind of
simplify
um that that conservation law into a
single expression under a common volume
integral okay
now again that's this relies on some
continuity that's why it's called the
continuity equation because this relies
on you know rho and f being continuously
varying they can't be really really
sharp shock waves in the system so if
there's shock waves in the system other
interesting things will happen and i'll
show you that in a little bit
okay awesome thank you and stay tuned
for for kind of the next video on this